[Music]  one of the most popular video games  right now is Skyrim it's one of those  big epic role-playing games and I found  out just a couple of hours ago that my  good pal Andy Richter did all the  character voices for the game no I was  lucky enough to get the job I do you  know I do did you voiceover work and  yeah for different things and this is a  big project I was surprised because I  would think this is a big deal and this  is a huge video getting this supposed to  be a lot of preparation involved in  doing that not really no and yeah I just  kind of went in and did what I do you  know didn't take long at all in fact I  have a reel of the character let's take  a look please sure is a mess  we're getting out of here things are on  fire and I don't  we all knowing mystical crab I have  information for you how I've been here  10 minutes no one's been dawei to me no  chips no salt  under high five troll I want a high five  like Barbie sorry  [Music]  [Applause]